je prends un consultant je suis un
lanceur d' alerte et je cherche d'autres
lanceurs d'alert pourquoi l'identité
numérique
on vous en a causé deux secondes vous
l'utilisez tous les jours c'est quoi ça
sert à quoi
c'est quoi les dérives où on va avec ça
donc très concrètement est ce qu'on
n'est pas en train de se mettre dans une
semoule absolument incroyable alors
l'identité numérique
on va commencer par déjà savoir où on
est si ça marche et ça marche a donc
aujourd'hui on se connaît de façon
simple on nous reconnaît de façon simple
pourquoi parce qu'on a une carte
d'identité
quand je vais quelque part j'arrive
j'arrive à l'aéroport je monte ma carte
d'identité on me dit vous êtes jérôme de
labriffe bonjour monsieur passé
circulez ya rien à voir ça c'était hier
aujourd'hui je suis plus une seule
personne
je suis toujours jérôme de labriffe avec
mes deux jambes et deux bras mais sur le
net j'ai watteville profil je vais avoir
mes profil facebook
je vais avoir mon profil instagram je
vais avoir mon profil mythique où est
très bien gros lapin allez voir c'est
marrant et donc finalement autant on
avait monsieur descartes en 15 100 96
qui nous amuser en disant je pense donc
je suis et maintenant on est rentré dans
le jeu table donc je suis concrètement
concrètement je vais pouvoir laisser sur
le net
toutes les informations possibles et
imaginables des photos des photos des
informations des traces etc etc
si je mets ces informations informelles
que je les adresse avec des informations
formel sur je mesure 1 mètre 70
je pèse quelques kilos de trop tout ça
va créer un certain nombre de profils
tout ça va créer mon identité numérique
et cette identité numérique qui va
évoluer au fur et à mesure des années
finalement elle a beaucoup plus de
valeur
que la simple photo sur ma carte
d'identité l'ess et les simples
informations que je vais avoir sur ma
carte d'identité donc très concrètement
je vais vous retrouver avec mon profil
numérique ou mais profil numérique
agréger les uns aux autres qui à
l'arrivée vont créer mon identité
numérique
alors là vous allez me dire ok très bien
jusque là ça va bien mais imaginez je
suis un ancien banquier et oui ça arrive
imaginez mon banquier mon banquier
demain pour me prêter du pognon il aura
beaucoup plus intérêt à utiliser mon
identité numérique dont toutes les
traces que j'ai laissé parce que quand
vous êtes comme quand vous êtes
confrontés un rendez vous commercial de
votre banque et le samedi matin aux
aurores pour avoir un prêt immobilier je
vous garantis que vous lui dites rien à
votre banque et donc votre banquier ce
qui va chercher c'est avoir le maximum
d'informations sur vous il va le
récupérer sur facebook
oui donc finalement tout ce que vous
êtes en train de laisser sur internet
toutes les traces que vous laissez sont
autant d'informations sont autant de
valeurs sont autant de profils sous ton
temps finalement de personnel des
digital qui font et qui formeront demain
la valeur de ce que vous êtes
concrètement votre banquier aura
beaucoup plus intérêt à prêter à votre
profil gros lapin cas jérôme de labriffe
qui arrive avec la tête un peu déchiré
le samedi matin à 9 heures corrigez moi
si j'ai tort donc on est rentré dans une
phase où finalement demain nous allons
avoir beaucoup plus d'intérêt ou plutôt
beaucoup plus de risques parce
qu'imaginez maintenant les risques que
ça crée d'avoir non pas une personne
physique incarner mais finalement des
profils et ce sont vos profils demain
qui vont vous gérez deuxième question
posée citoyens d'un pays où citoyens
digital et là on y est
à savoir
vous êtes aujourd'hui citoyen français
citoyens d'un citoyen belge citoyens de
ce que vous voulez vous êtes citoyen
d'un pays
vous avez la paternité ou plutôt vous
appartenez la paternité d'un pays
rappelez-vous nos amis facebook
instagram je vous en passe et des
meilleurs qui sont en train de récupérer
toutes les informations possibles et
imaginables sur vous qui se crée donc de
la valeur autour de vous et qui
potentiellement demain seront capables
et il ya des essais qui sont en train
d'être fait là dessus et ça va vous
faire un petit peu réfléchir qu'ils sont
capables de vous créer finalement votre
carte d'identité numérique votre carte
d'identité numérique demain pourra très
probablement être adressées par facebook
est utilisé par l'état français
vous êtes juriste dans la salle
regardez les questions que ça pose qui
sera donc capable de faire les lois est
ce que monsieur facebook sera demain
éventuellement celui qui fera les noix
pour l'état français
pourquoi pas ça peut s'imaginer qu'ils
qui éventuellement récupérera l'impôt si
ces messieurs facebook qui a votre
identité ou qui gère votre identité on
peut imaginer toutes les toute l'ailé où
toutes les actions régaliennes que ces
fameuses acteurs économiques pourront
remplacer en lieu et place d'un état
cette citoyenneté
cette citoyenneté digital pardon cette
citoyenneté digital est déjà à l'étude
chez google
ça vous laisse à penser un petit peu ou
est-ce que vous en serez dans quelques
années ce qui n'empêche que dont vous
êtes juriste c'est vous qui devez
réfléchir à ce genre de problème c'est
vous qui devez créer la réflexion
l'intelligence et les règles que nous
allons devoir
nous allons devoir mettre en place pour
essayer de contrecarrer ce type de ce
type d'action dernière chose n'oubliez
pas demain par rapport à ce que vous
expliquez comment vous allez vous
positionnez c'est à dire quel sera votre
identité donc de demain est ce que vous
avez entendu parler du brain a qui ne
savent ou cause un petit peu il ya de
très bons bouquins qui ont été faits sur
le sujet et qui montre deux choses
aujourd'hui vous allez avoir votre votre
incarnation vous êtes vous avez votre
vous avez votre cerveau très bien vous
avez votre corps votre cerveau tout va
bien on est en train je me rappelle de
développer les yachts et les fameuses
objets connectés
imaginez ces objets connectés je les
transferts sur un énorme ordinateur qui
va bien imaginez un ordinateur quantique
c'est très à la mode et ça arrive un
ordinateur quantique à l'intérieur de
l'ue tels je vais insérer les push
on va dire d'intelligence artificielle
d'articles intelligence pardon
artificielle vous en avez également
entendu parler fait le mix des deux on
arrive à ce qu'on appelle de
l'intelligence hybride l'intelligence
hybride de fait est capable de créer de
l'identité hybride c'est à dire que
demain vous ne serez plus seulement un
carnet et représenter parce que vous
êtes vous serez interne est représenté
par ce que vous n'êtes plus des données
qui auront été transmise à partir des
différents capteurs que vous aurez eu
sur vous objets connectés et l arrivée
le mix des deux parts de l'analyse va
créer autour de vous le moyen de vous
faire agir au delà de ce que votre
cerveau aurait lui même souhaitait faire
c'est à dire que je vais pouvoir influer
sur ce que vous voulez par l'injection
d'une certaine intelligence artificielle
de certain niveau d'intelligence
artificielle et donc je vais modifier
votre identité
donc aujourd'hui on est capable un
certain nombre d'expériences sont faits
sur le sujet c'est google qui est en
tête
amazon pas loin
oubliez pas les amazon web service is le
fameux à w s renseignez-vous là dessus
pour savoir où on pourra voir un petit
peu une idée de ce que ça représente
l'ensemble de ces technologies
l'ensemble de ces technologies est
aujourd'hui capable et le sera encore
plus demain d'interagir sur votre
cerveau et sur votre identité
alors je suis en train de vous
les boules jeu c'est tant mieux parce
que finalement dites-vous une chose et
10 en une chose nous ne sommes plus dans
le monde de oui oui la techno
aujourd'hui est en train de prendre une
place de plus en plus importante
en revanche vous dans cette salle vous
êtes des juristes ou des futurs juristes
donc si aujourd'hui la souris a déjà
pris en otage vos mains
si les écrans ont déjà également qu en
otage vos yeux ne laissez pas kidnappé
notre cerveau et vous êtes les gens qui
vont réfléchir autour d'une table et des
lois et des règles à mettre autour de
cette fameuse identité numérique donc si
j'ai une chose à vous demander s'il vous
plaît soyez avec moi à lanceur ou des
lanceurs d'alert nous en avons besoin
nous en aurons besoin on a besoin d'être
intelligent sur ces sujets et non pas
des suiveurs
merci
[Applaudissements]